ansible in open source automation tool
that can describe your it infrastructure
with simple declarative code it was
created by Michael DeHaan in 2012 then
acquired by Red Hat a few years later
and today is one of the most popular
configuration management tools most
importantly it uses declarative
push-based yaml code that allows devops
teams to easily automate their Linux
servers increasing efficiency while
reducing the likelihood of human error
it works by making at least one machine
a control node it then connects to
multiple manage nodes and sends them an
ansible module over SSH which can
configure that machine's dependencies
update network settings provision
databases or really any job that you
might need to do more than once
developers write playbooks that contain
a series of jobs called plays each play
is a set of instructions that can be
executed on one or more Target hosts it
will execute each task in order against
all machines in parallel in addition A
playbook is item potent which means it
won't actually make any changes unless
it has to in excellent real world use
case for ansible is to manage your Linux
servers on a platform like lenode we
start by provisioning a server running
Ubuntu as the control node then into it
from the terminal from there we can
install ansible on this machine this
machine needs permission to create and
modify other servers so we'll get an
access token for the lenode API and
store it somewhere securely now what's
awesome about ansible is that it has a
massive ecosystem of pre-built playbooks
that can be accessed on ansible Galaxy
installed a collection for lenode using
the ansible Galaxy command from there
it's a good practice to use ansible volt
to store sensitive information like a
password securely so it's not required
to be directly in a yaml file and will
want to encrypt our personal access
token here and now we're ready to write
our first Playbook create a file in the
develop and directory ending in Dot yml
and then create the first play by giving
it a name like create lenode instance
then the host property is a pattern that
defines one or more machines that will
run this play or they can be listed in a
dedicated inventory file next we can
Define reusable variables or point to
files that contain multiple variables
and then we can create a task list that
contains instructions that actually do
something here we're using a fully
qualified collection name of
lenode.cloud.instance which is a special
namespace that tells lenode to create a
new server instance from there we
describe the configuration details like
our API token region disk image and so
on and now all we have to do is run the
ansible Playbook command to create a new
server automatically and that's how you
automate infrastructure with code using
ansible shout out to lenode cloud
computing from Akamai for sponsoring
this awesome tool thanks for watching
and I will see you in the next one